on the forecourt of the future there
won't be queues for petrol because the
only thing on sale will be sustainable
locally sourced electrons well that's
one aim of today's net zero strategy
with nearly a billion pounds more
promised for green car grants and local
charging networks
it's a level of support that's even
surprised electric car campaigners but
many drivers like andy are far from
convinced i think the biggest challenge
is going to be making sure the
infrastructure is in place so that you
know if you've got all these electric
cars on the road well are people
actually going to be able to charge them
yeah so i think that's that's probably
the biggest challenge alongside of
course you know providing
support for people to make greener
choices okay you shouldn't be out of
pocket for doing the right thing
in addition to cars there's more money
for heat pumps home efficiency and green
aviation
according to boris johnson the injection
of public money will provide the spark
for a privately funded industrial
revolution green is good
green is right
green works
we need
urgent government action
but we must mobilize the markets we must
bring in the private sector because i
can i can deploy billions with the
approval of the chancellor obviously
but you
you in this room
you can deploy trillions but critics
argue those taxpayer billions need to be
tens of billions every year if we're
going to get anywhere close to our
climate targets there are two central
questions about the strategy published
today does it finally close the yawning
gap between government promises and
delivery and will it make the public
investment which is essential to ensure
the green transition is fair and creates
jobs and i'm afraid the answer to both
questions despite what he said is no the
plan falls short on delivery but what if
the government persuades everyone to buy
electric heat pumps in cars and then
doesn't have enough electricity to run
them
today's strategy promises a new nuclear
power plant probably here next to
sizewell b in suffolk to help fill the
gap
the size of this dome is quite deceptive
because inside the nuclear reactor is
only about four meters across no other
source of energy we've got quite packs
the punch you get from splitting atoms
heat from those nuclear reactions
generates steam which drives this
turbine that makes enough electricity to
more than a million homes and size well
b has got two of these
two proposed reactors here would power
six million more homes the industry says
nuclear is a natural fit the government
and actually the public understand that
we're going to get to net zero we need
new nuclear and we need to get on with
it 2050 is not very far away and we need
to have a decarbonized power supply by
2035.
the success of the strategy depends on
whether businesses can get behind it and
drive down the cost of going green so we
can all afford the benefits
right now it's far from certain if that
will happen
and net zero ambitions will remain just
that
tom clark sky news